Have you ever heard of the Hawaii chair? It's a gyrating desk chair which came on the market in 2007 and promised to give your abs a workout while you sat at your desk. It feels great on my abs. I can really feel this working. Hawaii chair while answering phones, using the computer, balancing books, or filing paperwork. It turned out, though, that office workers didn't want to hula at their desks, and the chair was a flop.
你听说过夏威夷椅吗？这是一款在2007年上市的旋转办公椅，号称能让你在坐在办公桌前的时候锻炼腹肌。我的腹肌感觉很好。我真的能感觉到它在起作用。在接听电话、使用电脑、对账或整理文件时使用夏威夷椅。然而事实证明，办公室职员并不想在办公桌前扭呼啦圈，这款椅子以失败告终。
Today, it's memorialized in the Museum of Failure, a pop-up exhibition of some of commerce's most misguided products. Other failures in the museum you might or might not remember. New Coke, Google Glass, the Newton, Colgate frozen lasagna, really, by the same company that makes toothpaste. The museum is funny, but its exhibits also highlight a serious point that psychologists say is underrated. There is no progress without failure, and that's as true for organizations as it is for individuals.
如今，它被永远留在了失败博物馆（Museum of Failure）中，这是一个展示商业界最误入歧途的产品的快闪展览。你可能还记得或者不记得馆里的其他失败产品。新可口可乐（New Coke）、谷歌眼镜（Google Glass）、牛顿掌上电脑（Newton）、高露洁冷冻千层面——真的，就是那家生产牙膏的公司。这个博物馆很有趣，但它的展品也凸显了一个心理学家认为被低估了的严肃观点。没有失败就没有进步，这对组织和对个人来说都是一样的。
So what's the difference between simply failing and failing well? How do you get past the emotional sting of failure, recognize its potential upsides, and learn from your mistakes? How can you set yourself up for productive failures in life, and how do companies and other organizations benefit from productive failures in the marketplace? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. You have two guests today. First is Dr. Amy Edmondson, the Novartis Professor of Leadership and Management at the Harvard Business School.
那么，单纯的失败和出色地失败有什么区别？你如何克服失败带来的情绪刺痛，认识到它的潜在优势，并从错误中吸取教训？在生活中，你如何为自己创造富有成效的失败，而公司和其他组织又如何从市场上的富有成效的失败中受益？欢迎收听美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客《心理学畅谈》（Speaking of Psychology），该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我们请到了两位嘉宾。首先是哈佛商学院诺瓦提斯领导力与管理学教授艾米·埃德蒙森（Amy Edmondson）博士。
She studies psychological safety, collaboration, and teamwork within and across organizations. She's won numerous awards for her work and has published. published dozens of articles in academic and other outlets, including the administrative science quarterly on the Harvard Business Review. Her latest book, The Right Kind of Wrong, The Science of Failing Well, was published in September. Next is Dr. Samuel West,
她研究组织内部以及组织之间的心理安全、协作和团队合作。她的工作赢得了众多奖项，并在《行政科学季刊》（Administrative Science Quarterly）和《哈佛商业评论》（Harvard Business Review）等学术及其他渠道发表了数十篇文章。她的最新著作《正确的一种错误：出色失败的科学》（The Right Kind of Wrong, The Science of Failing Well）于9月出版。接下来是塞缪尔·韦斯特（Samuel West）博士，
an organizational psychologist who studies and consults on creativity and innovation in the workplace. He founded the Museum of Failure in Sweden in 2017. The museum has since toured the world, stopping in Shanghai, Los Angeles, New York, and most recently in Washington, D.C., where the Speaking of Psychology team visited it last month. Thank you both for joining me today. So, Dr. Edmondson, let's start with you. In your book, you talk about three types of failure, basic, complex, and intelligent. What are these three types of failure? Why is it useful to
他是一名组织心理学家，专门研究和咨询工作场所的创造力和创新。他于2017年在瑞典创立了失败博物馆。此后，该博物馆一直在世界各地巡展，先后在上海、洛杉矶、纽约驻留，最近一次是在华盛顿特区，上个月《心理学畅谈》团队就在那里参观了该博物馆。感谢两位今天能来参加我的节目。那么，埃德蒙森博士，我们从您开始。在您的书中，您谈到了三种类型的失败：基本失败、复杂失败和智能失败。这三种失败是什么？为什么将它们这样分类
categorize them this way? Okay, they are, let's start at the bottom, basic failure. familiar territory where we actually have the knowledge to get it right and there's a single mistake made, a single cause that leads to a bad outcome, a failure. So those are both theoretically and practically often preventable. Complex failures are multi-causal. They're the perfect storms. They're the handful of factors that come together in just the wrong way to create a failed outcome. generally also in pretty familiar territory. And then finally we get to intelligent failures. These are, of course, the good kind, a right kind of wrong. And they are thoughtful forays in new territory that nonetheless failed to achieve the results we wanted.
很有用？好的，它们是——让我们从最底层的基本失败开始。这是熟悉的领域，我们实际上有能力把它做好，但却犯了一个单一的错误，单一的原因导致了糟糕的结果，即失败。因此，从理论和实践上讲，这些通常是可以预防的。复杂失败具有多重成因。它们是完美的风暴。它们是一系列因素以刚好错误的方式结合在一起，从而产生失败的结果。通常这也处于相当熟悉的领域。最后，我们迎来了智能失败。这些当然是好的一种，是正确的一种错误。它们是对新领域的深思熟虑的尝试，尽管如此，未能取得我们想要的结果。
So intelligent failures are driven by a goal. They're in new territory. You got a hypothesis. And they're no bigger than they have to be to get the learning. that you need from them. And I think the importance of a framework is it helps us avoid this sort of dichotomy between, you know, failure is bad, we need to avoid it
所以智能失败是由目标驱动的。它们处于新的领域。你有一个假设。而且它们的规模不会超过从它们那里获取所需学习成果的必要程度。我认为这个框架的重要性在于，它帮助我们避免了这种二分法，即：你知道，失败是坏事，我们需要避免它
and the sort of happy talk about failure, fail fast, have a failure museum, right? Versus, you know, making thoughtful distinctions that say, you know, some kinds of failures really are bad and we should do our very best to prevent them. And other kinds of failures we should literally have more of and in fact celebrate them. Dr. West, are the objects in the Museum of Failure, all products of intelligent failure, or do they fall into the other categories?
以及那种关于失败的快乐言论，比如“快速失败”、建立一个失败博物馆，对吧？与……相对的是，做出深思熟虑的区分，即：你知道，有些种类的失败确实很糟糕，我们应该尽最大努力去预防它们；而其他种类的失败，我们从字面意义上讲应该有更多，甚至应该庆祝它们。韦斯特博士，失败博物馆里的展品全都是智能失败的产品，还是说它们属于其他类别？
I would say most of them fall into the other category. Some of them are intelligent failures. So by nature of it being a museum with physical products, a lot of these products made it to market when they should never have made it to market. And by that definition, then they would be the bad kind of failure. But I think the underlying sort of aim of the museum is to drive home the point that we need to accept the, we need to accept failure in a broader sense even if we want progress or innovation. Now, it's up to the companies and the organizations behind these initiatives to get to do the right kind of failure. Now, I mentioned in the intro that my team and I visited the museum in Washington last month, where incidentally we did try the Hawaii chair on full speed.
我想说，大多数展品都属于其他类别。其中有一些是智能失败。由于它是一个实体产品的博物馆，许多产品在根本不应该上市的时候就推向了市场。按这个定义，它们就会属于糟糕的那类失败。但我认为博物馆背后的潜在宗旨是让人深刻认识到：如果我们想要进步或创新，我们就需要接受、在更广泛的意义上接受失败。现在，要做到正确地失败，这取决于这些举措背后的公司和组织。现在，我在开场白中提到，上个月我和我的团队参观了华盛顿的博物馆，顺便说一句，我们在那里确实以全速体验了夏威夷椅。
What was you like? Good for you. Nobody can see me doing this, but you're just wiggling like crazy. I don't know how you're supposed to concentrate on your work when you're shimmying like that. But while we were there, we talked to some of the other visitors and we wanted to know what they would ask you if they could, Dr. West. And one wanted to know more about why you decided to start the museum and whether it was just for fun. Or were there deeper lessons that you wanted the visitors to come away with?
感觉怎么样？真为你高兴。没有人能看见我这么做，但你只是在疯狂地扭动。我不知道当你那样扭来扭去的时候，怎么能集中精力工作。但当我们在那里时，我们和一些其他参观者交谈过，韦斯特博士，如果我们有机会，我们想知道他们会问你什么问题。其中一位想更多地了解你为什么决定创办这个博物馆，这仅仅是为了好玩吗？还是说你想让参观者从中领悟到更深层次的教训？
Yeah, I was doing research on organizational cultures for innovation or to boost that and enhance it. And one of the obstacles that I came across repeatedly was the fear of failure. So despite loads of books on creativity and innovation and management, and despite all the articles and consultants out there, people are still afraid of failing. And even in the coolest companies, even the most innovative companies, they're still afraid of failing.
是的，我当时在研究支持创新的组织文化，或者说旨在推动和增强创新的文化。我反复遇到的一大障碍就是对失败的恐惧。因此，尽管有大量关于创造力、创新和管理的书籍，尽管有所有的文章和顾问，人们仍然害怕失败。即使在最酷的公司里，即使在最具创新力的公司里，他们仍然害怕失败。
And no amount of consultants are going to make any difference there until people are willing to embrace, or at least accept the intelligent, with a good kind of failure. And so I started the museum just as a small little, I call it a nerdy innovation project because there was no, I had no ambitions or, you know, I didn't even think of it being interesting to anybody,
而且，在人们愿意拥抱——或者至少接受智能失败（也就是那种好的失败）之前，再多的顾问也不会起到任何作用。所以我创办这个博物馆只是作为一个小小的项目，我称之为“极客创新项目”，因为当时没有任何野心，你知道的，我甚至没想过它会对任何人产生吸引力，
but innovation nerds. So when we opened and got the media attention and the tension of the general public, I was kind of surprised, or I was very surprised rather. So yeah, the idea was to create a museum for innovation nerds, for teams that work within innovation to come and visit and have some productive discussions about failure, psychological safety, the other components that sort of make up that area.
除了创新极客之外。所以当我们开业并引起媒体注意以及广大公众的关注时，我有点惊讶，或者说我非常惊讶。所以是的，这个想法是为创新极客、为在创新领域工作的团队创造一个博物馆，让他们来参观并就失败、心理安全以及构成该领域的其他要素进行富有成效的讨论。
And yeah, it has functioned as that, but it has gotten much more attention outside of that realm as well. I think what's wonderful about it is that it does, it helps normalize failure and with humor, right? with a sense of humor. And, you know, even though I'm, you know, very enthusiastic about my classification system and more enthusiastic about intelligent failures than the other kind, I still realize that failures will always be with us, right? So of all kinds.
是的，它确实发挥了这样的作用，但它在这一领域之外也获得了多得多的关注。我认为它美妙的地方在于，它确实做到了——它帮助人们以幽默的方式将失败正常化，对吧？带着幽默感。而且，你知道，尽管我对我的分类系统充满热情，并且对智能失败的热情超过对其他类型失败的热情，但我仍然意识到失败将永远伴随着我们，对吧？各种各样的失败都会存在。
And that's got to be okay, too. Like the last chapter of my book is called Thriving as a Fallible Human Being. And I think that's what the museum helps people do, right? realize that failure is just part of life and let's, it makes us human. It is, it's like a bonding between us rather than a, you know, isolating experience. We had, I had, I had a visitors there sort of my aim within the museum is, yeah, we need to help help people appreciate failures, role for innovation. My secondary aim was to help organizations sort of understand that they can actually learn more from failure if they put some effort in.
这也是必须被接受的。就像我书的最后一章叫做《作为一个易错的人繁荣发展》（Thriving as a Fallible Human Being）。我认为这就是博物馆帮助人们做到的事，对吧？意识到失败只是生活的一部分，让我们……这让我们成为人类。它是人类之间的一种凝聚力，而不是一种孤立的体验。我们有……我在那里有几位参观者……我在博物馆内的宗旨是，是的，我们需要帮助人们理解失败对创新的作用。我的第二个宗旨是帮助组织理解，如果他们付出一些努力，他们实际上可以从失败中学习得更多。
to it based on an article by Amy. And then I didn't have any other aims with it. And then as visitors came and gave feedback, there was a third aim that sort of grew organically, which I think is best illustrated for an example of this couple who came to the museum when it was open in Sweden. They were very enthusiastic about the museum and they spent way too much time there, which I attributed to their lack of English. skills, but afterwards they were so enthusiastic, I wanted to talk to me, and they said,
基于艾米的一篇文章。然后我没有其他宗旨了。后来，随着参观者到来并给出反馈，第三个宗旨自然而然地成长起来，我认为这最好通过这对夫妇的例子来说明，他们在博物馆在瑞典开放时来参观过。他们对博物馆非常热情，在那里花了太多时间，我把这归咎于他们英语不好，但事后他们非常热情，想跟我谈谈，他们说，
we have made a major life decision right now after being in this museum. And I'm like, hey, we run a small Airbnb in Barcelona. And we've decided, after visiting your museum, that we, learning from the Microsoft, you know, the apples, the big boys here in innovation, we've learned that it's okay, it's good to take meaningful risks. So we've decided to, and then drum roll, change our breakfast menu. So they'd had the same breakfast menu for 20 years, and now they finally decided they're going to be willing to take that risk and they're going to put some fresh fruit on the menu. Wow. Wow. Right.
我们在参观完这个博物馆后，现在做出了一个重大的生活决定。我说：嘿，我们在巴塞罗那经营一家小型爱彼迎（Airbnb）。参观完你们的博物馆后，我们决定——向微软、苹果这些创新界的巨头学习，我们了解到：承担有意义的风险是可以的，也是件好事。所以我们决定——然后是鼓点声——改变我们的早餐菜单。因此，他们20年来一直是同一份早餐菜单，现在他们终于决定愿意承担这个风险，并打算在菜单上加入一些新鲜水果。哇。哇。对吧。
And I thought it was major impact. You've had an impact. Well, yeah. If that's what it took, then that's fantastic. But that's now become one of the third aims to help sort of people feel inspired and sort of, yeah, less afraid of taking this risk they need to take. Now, this was a fun story. but to do things that are meaningful when there are risks of failure, it's worth taking. Well, that leads me to this question, Dr. Edmondson, which is why do people find failure so difficult, so emotionally
我认为这产生了重大影响。你确实产生了影响。嗯，是的。如果这就是代价，那太棒了。但这现在成为了第三个目标之一，旨在帮助人们受到启发，并且在某种程度上，是的，不再那么害怕承担他们需要承担的风险。现在，这是一个有趣的故事，但在有失败风险的情况下做有意义的事情，是值得去做的。嗯，这让我想到了这样一个问题，埃德蒙森博士，那就是为什么人们会觉得失败如此困难，在情感上如此
painful, even when the stakes are low as they were in the case of changing a breakfast? Well, you know, I think there's many factors that contribute to our general aversion to failure, you know, emotional first among them. And probably some of this. is hardwiring, that we just don't like being confronted with our inadequacies, right? It scares us. It makes us feel that we might be, you know, rejected from the tribe. We might, we might literally have a, you know, a survival problem if, if others see us for the failures we secretly worry we might be. So it's a pretty understandable, maybe natural worry. but of course it's deeply unhelpful, right?
痛苦，即使在 stakes 很低的时候，就像改变早餐那样？嗯，你知道，我认为有许多因素导致了我们对失败的普遍厌恶，你知道，情感因素首当其冲。可能其中有些东西是天生的，我们就是不喜欢面对自己的不足，对吧？这让我们感到害怕。它让我们觉得我们可能会，你知道，被部落驱逐。如果我们，如果我们真的遇到了生存问题，如果，如果别人把我们看作是我们私下里担心自己可能会成为的那种失败者。所以这是一个非常可以理解的，也许是自然的担忧。但当然，这毫无帮助，对吧？
Because it doesn't help us take the kinds of risks that, you know, a full and successful life requires us to take. So do you have advice for steps that people can take to get past that emotional thing of failure? I mean, your book details stories of people who have failed massively and yet persevered and ultimately were successful. What were the character traits that were consistent among people? who were able to do that. But you know, that's a wonderful question. And it makes me think, you know, this is mine, mine is a book about failure. But really, it's meant to be a book about success.
因为它无助于我们承担那种，你知道，一个充实而成功的人生所要求我们承担的风险。那么，对于人们如何克服失败带来的那种情感冲击，你有什么建议吗？我的意思是，你的书详细记录了那些遭遇惨败却依然坚持不懈并最终取得成功的人的故事。那些能够做到这一点的人身上，有哪些共同的性格特征？你知道，这是一个很好的问题。这让我想起，你知道，这是一本关于失败的书。但实际上，它原本应该是一本关于成功的书。
It's about the central role of failure, especially in extreme success. You know, whether you're an Olympic athlete or an entrepreneur with a successful startup, up, real success can only come from that willingness to endure the failures along the way, because you will spend some portion of your time in new territory. And so the attributes that I think that truly successful people have in common, which allows them to withstand the temporary setback and assault, emotional assault to failure, are curiosity, right? They're sort of driven by that desire to find out, well, what if?
它是关于失败的核心作用的，尤其是在极端成功中。你知道，无论你是一名奥运运动员还是一个拥有成功初创企业的企业家，真正的成功只能来自于那种愿意承受一路上的失败的精神，因为你会将一部分时间花在新的领地上。因此，我认为真正成功的人所共有的属性，使他们能够承受暂时的挫折和攻击，也就是对失败的情感攻击，那就是好奇心，对吧？他们某种程度上被那种“如果……会怎样？”的渴望所驱动。
You know, what if I try this? What will happen? Persistence, for sure, a willingness to just pick right back up and try again despite the setback, despite the failure. And ability to appreciate both their own strengths and weaknesses. They aren't tied up in knots about being seen as inadequate in some way. They're just willing to be more honest, I think, with themselves and others. others about reality. And so I think that's, it's mainly about that persistence, that curiosity and that openness,
你知道，如果我尝试这个会怎么样？会发生什么？坚持不懈，这是一定的，愿意在遭遇挫折、遭遇失败后马上重新振作并再次尝试。并且能够欣赏自己的长处和短处。他们不会纠结于自己在某种程度上显得不够优秀。我认为他们只是愿意对自己和他人更诚实，
openness to the data of their own experience. Dr. West, turning back to the museum for a minute, were some of the items that you included just mistakes, not really failures? I mean, how did you decide on the products that you have in there? And how did you get them? I like the definition. I can't remember where I took this from, but the failure is defined as a deviation
对现实更诚实。所以我觉得，这主要在于那种坚持、那种好奇心和那种开放的心态，
from expected of desired results. It might have been your article, Amy. Might have been. It might have been. And the, so that's been the guiding criteria sort of defining what failure is. It's not always a commercial or a financial failure. So to be in the museum,
对他们自己经历的数据持开放态度。韦斯特博士，我们把话题转回博物馆一会儿，你展出的一些物品只是失误，而并非真正的失败？我的意思是，你是如何决定馆内藏品的？又是如何获得它们的？我很喜欢这个定义。我不记得我是从哪里看到这个定义的了，但失败被定义为偏离
it had to be a failure of some sort, the artifacts or, and they have to have been an innovation. So it can't just be something. People keep asking me to put in the Samsung phone that caught on fire a few years ago. Remember that? Oh, yeah. Airplanes. Yeah.
了预期或期望的结果。那可能是你的文章，艾米。可能吧。也许吧。所以，这就是指导标准，用以定义什么是失败。它并不总是一个商业或财务上的失败。因此，要想进入博物馆，
So I was like, that wasn't an innovation. That was just bad production. Right. Just a basic failure. Yeah, that's not interesting at all. So it has to be where someone was pushing the boundary or, They were trying to do something new. That's great.
它必须在某种程度上是失败的，这些文物，而且它们必须是一项创新。所以它不能只是某种东西。人们一直要求我把几年前着火的三星手机放进去。还记得那个吗？哦，对。飞机。对。
That's actually great. It's a very important criteria. That's a nice boundary for your exhibits. Because it's true, as you said earlier, that not all of them are strictly speaking intelligent. They're at least all in the space of innovation. They were earnest attempts to do something new and innovative. I did make an exception for the section of the museum on Donald Trump, because there wasn't much innovation.
所以我当时想，那不是创新。那只是生产糟糕。对吧。只是一个基础的失败。对，那一点也不有趣。所以它必须是某人突破界限的地方，或者他们试图做一些新的事情。那太棒了。那其实很棒。这是一个非常重要的标准。这对你的展品来说是一个很好的界限。因为正如你刚才所说，这确实是真的，并不是所有的展品都严格意义上是聪明的失败。它们至少都在创新的领域里。它们是试图做一些新的和创新事情的真诚尝试。我确实为博物馆里关于唐纳德·特朗普的部分破例了，因为那里并没有多少创新，
going on, but there's a lot of failure. Right. So that criteria. And then the third criteria is that I have to find it interesting, which is very easy because I'm interested in everything. And getting the items was in the beginning, you're going to, both are you going to laugh at me now, but I honestly thought, because of my work in the space for years,
但有很多失败。对吧。所以这是那个标准。然后第三个标准是我必须觉得它有趣，这非常容易，因为我对什么都感兴趣。而获取这些藏品在刚开始时——你们现在可能会笑话我，但我真的以为，因为我在这个领域工作多年，
I thought I could just call up the innovation director of companies, in the ABC and say, hey, John, I'm opening this cool museum. It's going to be really awesome. Send me some of your stuff. Let me embarrass your corporation. Yeah, sure. None of them wanted to be part of it. And then, so I just had to buy the stuff online through Craigslist and eBay and whatnot.
我以为我可以给ABC公司那些创新总监打电话，然后说，嘿，约翰，我正在开办这个很酷的博物馆。这将会非常棒。给我寄点你们的东西。让我来羞辱一下你们公司。是的，当然。他们中没有人想参与其中。然后，所以我只能通过Craigslist和eBay之类的网站在线购买这些东西。
And that was until we opened. And since we opened, I get donations both from individuals and from companies. Many of the companies that are represented there have donated items themselves, knowing that, I mean, failure is having a bit of a moment right now in the corporate space. So it's kind of cool to be open to failure. So right now it's about it's a mix, it's donations from individuals and companies. I just want to say some of the things that I saw on there seem to me not to be failures exactly, but maybe products whose time passed. I'm thinking of blockbuster video in particular, but I'm also not convinced that the segue was a true failure. Oh, you can't open that kind of worms right there.
直到我们开馆。自从我们开馆以来，我得到了个人和公司的捐赠。许多有展品代表的公司自己也捐赠了物品，因为他们知道，我的意思是，失败现在在企业界有点流行。所以对失败持开放态度挺酷的。所以现在差不多是个人和公司捐赠的混合体。我只是想说，我看到的一些东西在我看来并不完全是失败，而可能是产品过时了。我特别想到了百视达录音带（Blockbuster Video），但我也并不确信赛格威（Segway）真的是个失败。哦，你不能在那里打开潘多拉的魔盒。
Well, the segue, so based on the definition of failure of being a deviation for expected results, the segue was expected to revolutionize the way people transport themselves. The segue was expected to sell one billion U.S. in one year. year, the segue was expected to, and this is a real quote from a real Silicon Valley big shot, the segue was expected to be bigger than the internet. So, and city infrastructures were to be built around the seg, future city infrastructures were to be built around the segways. So all these expectations were have never been, not even close to being met. So by the definition, the segue certainly belongs in the music. Yeah, their goals.
好吧，关于赛格威，根据失败是“偏离预期结果”的定义，赛格威曾被期望彻底改变人们的出行方式。赛格威曾被期望在一年内售出十亿美元。赛格威曾被期望，这是硅谷某大人物的真实名言，赛格威曾被期望比互联网还要大。所以，并且城市基础设施将围绕赛格威建造，未来的城市基础设施将围绕赛格威建造。所以所有这些期望从来没有，甚至连接近实现都没有。所以根据定义，赛格威绝对属于博物馆。是的，它们的目标
clearly were met with failure. Totally. I mean, it's still a cool product. It was and still is a cool product. Yeah. Absolutely. Absolutely. Well, Dr. Evanston, let me ask you this.
显然遭遇了失败。完全是这样。我的意思是，它依然是一个很酷的产品。它过去是，现在依然是一个很酷的产品。是的。绝对是。绝对是。好吧，埃德蒙森博士，请允许我问你这个问题。
When you try something new, there's always an opportunity for failure. But when you're taking a leap, how do you set yourself up to fail well if it doesn't work out? Well, I think the most important criterion is that you've done your homework. And I don't mean, you know, years. and years of deep research before you're willing to try something new. Of course not. But that you've done at least the bare minimum to find out what do we know, what do we not know, and what's my well-reasoned hypothesis about why this might work?
当你尝试新事物时，总会有失败的机会。但是当你迈出这一步时，如果事情没有成功，你该如何为自己做好失败的准备呢？嗯，我认为最重要的标准是你已经做了功课。我指的不是，你知道，在愿意尝试新事物之前进行几年又几年的深入研究。当然不是。而是你至少做了最低限度的准备，去了解我们知道什么，我们不知道什么，以及我对这为什么可能奏效的合理解释是什么？
You're not setting out to fail. And that would be sabotage, not experimenting. You're setting out and hoping, you know, you're really hoping that you're right because the upside seems good to you. And yet, despite having done, so you set people up to fail well when you just remind them, do your homework. You know, do a quick search, read the literature, whatever, depending on what the domain is, talk to a handful of customers to see what they think. I mean, you know, get your ducks in a row and then go for it. I'd like to add on to that.
你不是为了失败而出发的。那是蓄意破坏，而不是实验。你出发并怀着希望，你知道，你真的希望自己是对的，因为对你来说好的一面似乎很好。然而，尽管已经做到了，所以当你提醒人们“做好功课”时，你就是在为他们做好失败的准备。你知道，快速搜索一下，阅读文献，或者其他什么，取决于具体领域，和几个客户聊聊看看他们的想法。我的意思是，你知道，把你的事情安排妥当，然后放手去做。我想补充一点。
There's a quote that I've stolen, and I have absolutely no idea who said this, but. I love it. It's not a, it's not failure if you call it an experiment. So, and I mean, you can laugh at it. But there's something, there's something really good to it. No, it's true. If you design it as an experiment, say, we're going to, we've done our homework. We've got all the information we need.
有一句名言我借用过，完全不知道是谁说的，但我很喜欢。如果不叫失败，那就叫实验。所以，我的意思是，你可以对此一笑置中。但这里面确实有些，有些非常棒的道理。不，这是真的。如果你把它设计成一个实验，说，我们要，我们已经做好了功课。我们掌握了所需的所有信息。
We're going to take a risk that when it fails, it doesn't damage the organization or cost lives or suffering. We're going to test it in a realistic environment. See what happens. And if it fails, hey, Great, let's learn from it. It's data. It's data. It's just.
我们要承担这样一个风险：当它失败时，不会对组织造成损害，也不会付出生命或痛苦的代价。我们要在现实的环境中测试它。看看会发生什么。如果失败了，嘿，太好了，从中吸取教训。这就是数据。这就是数据。这只是。
And that's, to me, that's the most brilliant type of failure. But don't we, we have a tendency not to want to share our failures. For example, research journals don't publish studies with null results. In other words, the results don't support the underlying thesis. So how can we learn if information is hidden or suppressed? Well, I think you're saying that it doesn't have. happen naturally and automatically. And a lot of our institutions are set up in a way that prevent the sharing of failures in such a way that it would help prevent the production of the
对我来说，这是最精彩的一种失败。但我们难道不倾向于不想分享我们的失败吗？例如，研究期刊不会发表结果为零的研究。换句话说，结果不支持基础论题。那么，如果信息被隐藏或压制，我们又该如何学习呢？嗯，我想你的意思是它不会自然而然、自动地发生。我们的许多机构在建立时，都以某种方式阻止了失败的分享，而这种分享本可以帮助防止
same failure a second time, right? Because it hardly needs to be said, but an intelligent failure the second time around isn't really intelligent. So, you know, how do we, in fact, how do we do better is really the question here? How do we help, you know, scientists become aware that someone else has already tried that and it didn't work. Oftentimes, you know, the answer lies in the networks and the conferences and the more informal sharing that they do and that they're aware of to learn as much as they can so that we're not wasting time and resources redoing a previously failed experiment. But you're right to point to this as a real challenge. Well, we'll open data and open science help in that respect? I suppose that's the idea. And we have to overcome that human
同样的失败再次发生，对吧？因为不用多说，第二次出现智能失败其实并不算真正的智能失败。所以，你知道，我们如何，实际上我们如何做得更好才是这里真正的问题？我们如何帮助，你知道，科学家们意识到其他人已经尝试过那个方法而且行不通。通常情况下，你知道，答案在于他们所做的网络、会议以及更非正式的分享，他们意识到这些分享是为了尽最大努力去学习，这样我们就不会浪费时间和资源去重做之前失败的实验。但你指出这是一个真正的挑战是正确的。那么，开放数据和开放科学会有所帮助吗？我想这就是这个想法。我们必须克服人类的
tend to the human factor, the human factor, which is I want to look good, not bad. I'm much more interested in publicizing my successes than my failures. But when we can appreciate that this is in our own best interest, especially collectively, you know, to share and share widely, then we become more willing to do it. My dream is to start a journal, an academic, proper peer-reviewed journal, high-quality, but the journal of null results, like statistically insignificant results, you know? Right. And just like, no, you can do high-quality research, and instead of massaging the data until you get positive results, we'll actually publish when you've spent a lot of time and the the differences are zero.
倾向，即人类因素，人类因素就是我想看起来很好，而不是很糟糕。我对外宣扬我的成功远比宣扬我的失败更感兴趣。但当我们能够认识到这最符合我们自己的利益，尤其是集体利益时，你知道，去分享并广泛分享，然后我们就变得更愿意去做了。我的梦想是创办一本期刊，一本学术性的、真正同行评审的期刊，高质量的，但专门发表结果为零的期刊，比如统计学上不显著的结果，你知道吗？没错。就像，不，你可以做高质量的研究，而不是为了得到阳性结果而篡改数据，当你们花了很多时间却发现差异为零时，我们实际上会将其发表出来。
It would be much more interesting. And the reason peer review could work there is because you would only accept a paper if the hypotheses were thoughtful, if they had good grounding in the literature. So this wouldn't be just like silly stuff. No, no. Yeah, it would be that, yeah, a reasonable person would have thought that would work, but it didn't. Thank you so much for telling me because now I don't waste a lot of.
那会更有趣。同行评审之所以能在那里发挥作用，是因为只有当假设经过深思熟虑、在文献中有很好的依据时，你才会接受一篇论文。所以这不会只是些愚蠢的东西。不，不。是的，就是那种，是的，一个理性的人会认为那会行得通，但结果没有。非常感谢你告诉我，因为现在我不用浪费很多
I should do the same. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'll hook you up with our chief publishing officer. Yeah, starting at journalism. Is something you do on a weekend? Right, right.
我也该这么做。是的。是的。是的。我帮你联系我们的首席出版官。是的，创办一份期刊。这是你周末会做的事吗？对，对。
Not high on the list, maybe, but it's a great idea. So Dr. West, speaking again about the museum, is there any exhibit in there that you feel is like the most massive of all the failures? And if so, why? No, I mean, that's, you're asking the, most impossible question here. I mean, some of them are
也许不在优先列表的前端，但这真是个好主意。韦斯特博士，再次谈到博物馆，里面有没有哪个展品让你觉得是所有失败中最巨大的？如果是的话，为什么？不，我是说，你问的是，这里最不可能回答的问题。我是说，其中一些
not interesting to the visitors, but I find them infinitely interesting because there's a great story behind them. There's a quote by Leo Tolstoy that I've changed for the museum. The original
对游客来说没有什么意思，但我发现它们极其有趣，因为它们背后都有一个伟大的故事。列夫·托尔斯泰有一句名言，我为博物馆做了一些修改。原话是
quote is, all happy families are alike, but every unhappy family is unhappy in their own special way. And I like that because it's true of the items in the museum as well, where successful innovation sort of follows, yeah, it makes sense, you know. But items in the museum, there's so many ways on this, on the tricky road of successful innovation to fail.
所有幸福的家庭都是相似的，而不幸的家庭各有各的不幸。我很喜欢这句话，因为对于博物馆里的展品来说也是如此，成功的创新有点遵循着，是的，这说得通，你知道的。但对于博物馆里的展品来说，在成功创新这条棘手的道路上，有太多的失败方式。
And they seem to fail in different ways and in different contexts. Some of them, like you said, were ahead of their time. Some were way behind their time. some of just stupid ideas. There's all kinds of different reasons for failure. And the biggest ones, the most interesting ones, maybe aren't the most fun items to look at. One of my favorite, and I know people are bored with this example,
而且它们似乎以不同的方式、在不同的背景下失败。有些像你说的，超前于它们的时代。有些则大大落后于它们的时代。有些纯粹是愚蠢的点子。导致失败的原因形形色色。而最大的、最有趣的，也许并不是最有趣的展品。我最喜欢的一个，我知道人们对这个例子已经感到厌烦了，
but I love the story of Kodak and how they invented the digital camera. Do you know when? It's early. It's early. When? I don't know, but I know it's stunningly early. Okay. Uh,
但我喜欢柯达的故事，以及他们是如何发明数码相机的。你知道是什么时候吗？很早。很早。什么时候？我不知道，但我知道它早得惊人。好吧。呃，
1958. Okay, you, you were way, you're way ahead. This is, this is, they, I mean,
1958年。好吧，你，你猜得太远了，你远远走在前面了。这是，这是，他们，我的意思是，
it was actually crazy. Right. Yeah, that's crazy. It was actually equally crazy in the, in the early 70s. Yeah.
这实际上太疯狂了。对。是的，太疯狂了。在70年代初，实际上同样疯狂。是的。
Yeah. And then, um, and then Kodak became this, uh, you know, they were the richest. They were the Googler or the Apple of yesterday year.
是的。然后，嗯，然后柯达变成了这个，你知道的，他们是最富有的。他们是昔日的谷歌或苹果。
They couldn't, they were big. They had all the money and the best engineers. And they were the best at innovation. But, They didn't know how they were unwilling to change their business model. So they tried, up until their bankruptcy, they tried to get people to print photos, which no one was doing in 2012. And buying expensive photo paper and film.
他们不可一世。他们拥有所有的资金和最好的工程师。他们是创新的佼佼者。但是，他们不知道该如何，或者不愿意改变他们的商业模式。因此，直到破产前，他们一直试图让人们打印照片，而到2012年时根本没有人这么做，他们还试图让人购买昂贵的相纸和胶卷。
So people say, oh, yeah, Kodak doesn't exist. It was the iPhone, the distort. No, it wasn't. They made the cameras for Apple, you know. it was an inability to be flexible with the business model and innovate on that part of the business. And I'm fascinated, right? Because there's so many nuances to it.
所以人们会说，哦，是的，柯达不复存在了。是因为iPhone，是颠覆。不，根本不是。他们为苹果代工相机，你知道的。这是无法灵活调整商业模式并在业务的那部分进行创新的结果。我感到很着迷，对吧？因为这里面有太多的细微差别。
But at the museum, it's just a camera. Right, right. The short, short, short. You need the story behind it to really understand why it's a failure. But then I like the funny ones as well. I like the, I like the silly ones. I'm the hula chair or the, I got a donation in Brooklyn. a cabbage patch doll that was called meal time or snack time.
但在博物馆里，它只是一个相机。对，对。简短，简短，简短。你需要背后的故事来真正理解为什么它是一个失败。但我也喜欢滑稽的。我喜欢，我喜欢那些傻气的。我是呼啦椅的狂热粉丝，或者我在布鲁克林收到过一个捐赠，是一个叫进餐时间或点心时间的发育宝娃娃（Cabbage Patch Kids）。
And somebody donated said, you can have this cannibal if you take care of her. I was like, what's this crazy man talking about? It was a cabbage patch doll that had an eating mechanism. So you could feed it little plastic food items. And then it would end up in a backpack on the dog. So it's a fun idea, I guess.
有人捐赠时说，如果你照顾好她，这个食人魔就归你了。当时我想，这个疯子在胡说八道些什么？那是一个带进食机制的发育宝娃娃。你可以喂它吃一小块一小块的塑料食物。然后食物最终会进入娃娃背上的背包里。所以，我想这算是个有趣的点子。
The problem was that it also liked to eat children. finger and heart. That one is just funny, you know. Well, getting a little more serious for a moment, Dr. Edmondson, you study something called psychological safety. What is it and why is it important to have in order to benefit from failure? Probably the simplest way to put it is that psychological safety describes a learning environment, an environment where people are willing and able to take the interpersonal
问题在于它也喜欢吃小孩子的。手指和心。那个真的很好笑，你知道的。好了，言归正传，埃德蒙森博士，您研究过一种叫做“心理安全感”的东西。它是什么？为什么为了从失败中受益而拥有它至关重要？最简单的说法大概是，心理安全感描述了一种学习环境，在这种环境中，人们愿意并且能够承担学习行为所涉及的人际交往
risks that learning behaviors involve. Speaking up with a crazy idea, you know, running an experiment that might end in failure, asking for help when you're in over your head, offering a dissenting point of view. Those are all human behaviors that can feel risky at work. And yet, without engaging in them, your team can't learn. So psychological safety describes that learning climate where you just believe, yeah, Of course, we do those things around here because that's what we do. That's what we need to do to be good.
风险。提出一个疯狂的想法，你知道的，进行一个可能以失败告终的实验，在超出自己能力范围时寻求帮助，或者提出不同的观点。这些都是在工作中可能让人觉得有风险的人类行为。然而，如果不参与这些行为，你的团队就无法学习。因此，心理安全感描述了那种学习氛围：你坚信，是的，当然，我们这里会做这些事情，因为这就是我们的做事方式。这就是我们为了变得优秀所需要做的事情。
But it's not the norm. I'm starting to see, you know, writing out there where some people, some companies are saying psychological safety is table stakes. Like, you've got to give that to your employees or else, you know, you shouldn't even be in business, right? Like, you know, like food and water. It's like, no. You know, actually psychological safety is an aspiration. It's an environment where we just do all these unnatural things that are needed for innovation and learning. And we've trained ourselves in that kind of fun, toughness that we need to be great and to innovate and to have experiments.
但这不是常态。我开始看到，你知道，一些文章中写道，有些公司认为心理安全感是基本门槛。就像，你必须给你的员工提供这个，否则，你知道的，你甚至都不应该经商，对吧？就像，你知道的，就像食物和水一样。其实不然。你知道，实际上心理安全感是一种愿景。它是一种环境，在这里我们只是做所有那些对于创新和学习必不可少的、违反天性的事情。我们在那种成为伟大、创新和进行实验所必需的有趣的坚韧中训练了自己。
And so, you know, it's been misinterpreted in that sense as, you know, like emotional safety or something. And it's really about learning and candor and being uncomfortable. There's a big misconception that psychological safety is about everybody being friends and everybody. Yeah. Feeling comfortable. No. No. It happens.
因此，你知道，它在某种程度上被误解了，被当作情感安全或类似的东西。而它实际上关乎学习、坦诚以及感到不适。有一个很大的误解，认为心理安全感就是让每个人都成为朋友，让每个人。是的。都感到舒服。不。不。这种情况时有发生。
I see it all the time. Like, no, no, no, no. No, it's not about saying, yes, everything is great. Yeah, no. Because then that makes it so hard for us to disagree with each other. I don't think that's going to work, Sam. Right. Like, how do we, you know, let's step back.
我经常看到。不，不，不，不。不，它不是指去说，是的，一切都好。不。因为那样会让我们很难互相表达异议。我觉得那行不通，萨姆。对。比如，我们怎么能，退一步讲。
Let's think this through. Yeah, Amy, that was a stupid idea. Right. And then you're saying, like, inside your head at that moment, you're going, I hate her, right? Right. And it's just like, you can't help it. You're human, right? So, but it's an environment where we realize, you know, we have kind of devoted ourselves
让我们仔细想想。是的，艾米，那是个愚蠢的主意。对。然后你心里想的是，在那一刻，你在想，我恨她，对吧？对。这是情不自禁的。你是人，对吧？所以，但这是一个我们意识到，你知道的，我们已经致力于
to doing it anyway. Well, Dr. West, you consult to corporations. What do you tell them when you're seeing the kind of behavior that isn't helping them to learn from their failures? I mean, a lot of my focus is on psychological. safety sort of as sort of first like the the the museum and what can we what kind of learnings can we extract from the stories of the artifacts in the museum and especially those that are relevant to the industry or to the to the client but then my main focus
无论如何都要这样做的环境。韦斯特博士，您为企业提供咨询。当您看到那种无助于他们从失败中学习的行为时，您会告诉他们什么？我的许多重点其实放在心理安全上，首先把它当作博物馆那种模式，我们可以从博物馆文物的这些故事中提取出什么样的学习成果，尤其是那些与行业或客户相关的成果，但在此之后，
after that is on psychological safety and there's I see it more as starting the conversation about it and sort of explaining like yeah it's really simple I mean it's a simple construct but it's very difficult to establish. Right. Simple, but not easy. Yeah. Yeah. It's like exercise. You're eating right. You know, it's really simple. Yeah. But you just can't get it right. So, so I and I love, I love how psychological safety fits well in with the aim of the, of the museum and, and gives my clients something to continue to work with.
我的主要重点是心理安全，我更多地将其视为开启关于这一话题的对话，并解释说，是的，这真的很简单。我的意思是，这是一个简单的概念，但建立起来非常困难。没错。说起来容易，做起来难。是的。就像锻炼身体。你吃得健康。你知道的，这真的很简单。是的。但你就是做不对。所以，我，我喜欢心理安全感如何很好地契合博物馆的目标，并为我的客户提供可以继续努力的方向。
I have a good story on psychological safety if you can be bothered. Yeah, go for it. So I was doing a workshop for a big sort of luxury brand and they flew in their entire innovation department to the museum. It was all great. And we were, there was probably 15 of us in a room, top senior management of the whole operation.
如果你不嫌烦的话，我有一个关于心理安全感的好故事。行，说来听听。当时我在为一个大型奢侈品品牌做研讨会，他们把整个创新部门都飞到了博物馆。一切都很好。当时房间里大概有15个人，全是整个业务部门的最高高层管理人员。
And we did the introduction round. and there was one guy there who'd just been hired like six months ago. And so I started my workshop. It was focused on psychological safety. And I've been doing this a while. I think I'm pretty good at it. But 20 minutes in, the newest part of the leadership team, he's like, excuse me. And he says it's in front of his seniors.
我们进行了自我介绍环节。其中有一个人是刚招进来的，大概才六个月。于是我开始了我的研讨会。重点是心理安全感。我干这行有一段时间了。我觉得自己做得还不错。但20分钟后，这位领导团队中最年轻的成员说，打扰一下。他当着自己上司的面说出了这句话。
He says, excuse me, what is psychological safety? And I felt like, you idiot. I've been, that's what this workshop is about. This is what I mean. What kind of PowerPoint slides have you been looking at? Like how simple do you want me to spell this out to? That was my sort of. Inside voice.
他说，打扰一下，什么是心理安全感？我当时的感觉是，你这个笨蛋。我一直在，这就是这个研讨会的主题。这就是我的意思。你到底看的是什么样的PPT？你希望我把这个解释得有多简单？那是我的
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And then I was like, and I felt like, okay, this is, this is too strange. Like they've obviously hired him because he's, he can't be stupid. He's obviously a smart guy. And then I realized. by him being the most junior person on that team,
内心独白。对。对。对。然后我想，我觉得，好吧，这太奇怪了。他们招他进来肯定是因为他，他不可能是个笨蛋。他显然是个聪明人。然后我意识到，
being willing to ask me that, I'm not Amy Edmondson, but I'm pretty good at psychological safety, to ask me, in front of his bosses, you know, to say, I don't get this. Thank you, Mr. Workshop dude, but I don't understand what you're saying.
作为团队中最资历最浅的人，他愿意问我这个问题——我虽然不是埃德蒙森，但我在心理安全感方面还算不错——他敢于当着老板的面问我，你知道的，说，我听不懂。谢谢你，研讨会先生，但我真的不明白你在说什么。
By him asking that, it showed so clearly what psychological safety was. They had it. He took a risk. He took a massive risk. Yeah. And he believed, I think almost by definition, that that was expected, right? If you don't know.
通过提出这个问题，他非常清晰地展现了什么是心理安全感。他们具备这种环境。他承担了风险。他冒了巨大的风险。是的。而且他相信，几乎可以说是必然的，这是大家所期望的，对吧？如果你不懂的话。
And that was. Yeah. If you don't understand. And he wasn't going to be penalized for it. He was, nobody rolled their eyes at him. We had a great discussion. I flipped it and said, wow, what a great provision of psychological safety. This was.
就是这样。是的。如果你不理解。而且他不会因此受到惩罚。没有人对翻他白眼。我们进行了一场精彩的讨论。我顺势转折了一下说，哇，这真是心理安全感的一个绝佳体现。这就是当时的情况。
But it was just a beautiful demonstration of. psychological safety in action in a workshop, which I could have probably improved on psychological safety. I love that. It was a good example of that. So it's got to be a place where it's true when somebody says there are no stupid questions. There really are no stupid questions. Yep. Yeah. So it's hard for adults to deal with failure, but what about kids? What's the best way to talk to children to help them to learn to see the value in taking risks even when they might fail? You know, someone suggested to me recently that I should write a book for kids on this very topic for that for that very reason that after a certain age, I don't know exactly what age it is, but probably around five kids do in fact start to get failure of verse. But before that, not at all.
但这只是在工作坊中对心理安全感的一次极好的实际演示，也许我在心理安全感上本可以做得更好。我太喜欢了。这是一个很好的例子。所以，当有人说没有愚蠢的问题时，那必须是一个真正如此的地方。真的没有愚蠢的问题。是的。是的。所以，成年人很难应对失败，但孩子们呢？与孩子对话的最好方式是什么，帮助他们学会看到冒险的价值，即使他们可能会失败？你知道，最近有人建议我应该就这个主题为孩子们写本书，正是出于这个原因，因为在某个年龄之后，我不知道具体是哪个年龄，但大概五岁左右，孩子们事实上开始变得害怕失败。但在那之前，一点也不。
See, they'd never learn to walk. They'd never, you know, they'd never learned to talk. They'd never learned to do anything if they weren't willing to go for it. and fail along the way. And yet, I would say sometime in elementary school, they start to get the message. Like, oh, I'm supposed to have the right answer. I'm supposed to get. My worth is about being right, being smart, being accepted, not about, you know, taking risk.
你看，如果他们不愿意去尝试并在过程中失败，他们就永远学不会走路。他们永远学不会说话。他们永远学不会做任何事。然而，我想说，在小学的某个时候，他们开始接收到这样的信息。比如，哦，我应该给出正确的答案。我应该得到。我的价值在于正确、聪明、被接受，而不是在于去冒险。
So I think for parents, first of all, they have to really catch themselves and correct the behavior. That's so spontaneous to say, oh, great job, like for everything. And instead, comment on process. Oh, interesting how you tried to do it that way. What did you learn? Like, just keep modeling learning behavior with your kids, celebrating their little forays into new territory, asking them, what did you learn from that?
所以我认为对于父母来说，首先，他们必须真正克制自己并纠正这种行为。那种对每件事都脱口而出“哦，做得好”的行为是如此自然。取而代之的是，要评论过程。哦，真有趣你是怎么尝试那样做的。你学到了什么？就像这样，不断与你的孩子一起塑造学习行为，庆祝他们进入新领域的小小尝试，问他们，你从中学到了什么？
And being enthusiastic about the lessons that they deliver, which may be different than the ones that you assumed they learned from that. So it's really about modeling that learning orientation and celebrating the discoveries more than the outcomes. I have to blame school as well. I mean, about that age, six, they start school and start getting grades. And then everything becomes about getting the right answer rather than learning something. And that's a huge, I think it's not, I mean, the parents, of course, have their responsibility, but the school definitely has a responsibility there. And, you know,
并且对他们带来的经验保持热情，这些经验可能与你假设他们从中学到的东西不同。所以这实际上是关于塑造这种学习导向，庆祝发现而不是结果。我也得怪学校。我是说，大约在六岁那个年纪，他们开始上学并开始获得成绩。然后一切都变成关于得到正确答案，而不是学习某些东西。这是一个巨大的问题，我认为这不仅——我是说，父母当然有他们的责任，但学校绝对负有责任，而且，你知道，
is it the right answer you want or is it the learning you want? And the school is all across the world has failed at that. Is it possible to be too cavalier about failure? And I ask this because in its early days, Facebook's internal motto was famously move fast and break things. And even Mark Zuckerberg finally backed off from the break things part. Do you find, how do you find the right balance of innovation, risk-taking, and caution? The fail-fast and break-things sort of Silicon Valley motto, it's gotten, it's not, it's thoughtless, it's careless. And so failure costs money, it costs suffering, it costs prestige, it costs relationships,
你想要的是正确的答案还是你想要的是学习？全世界的学校在这方面都失败了。对失败过于轻率可能吗？我问这个问题是因为在早期，Facebook内部著名的座右铭是“快速行动并打破常规”。甚至马克·扎克伯格最终也从“打破常规”这一点上退缩了。你觉得，你如何找到创新、冒险和谨慎之间的正确平衡？硅谷那种“快速失败并打破常规”的座右铭，它变得，它不是，它是轻率的，它是粗心的。所以失败需要付出金钱代价，它带来痛苦，它损害声誉，它影响人际关系，
failure is nothing we ever want. If we're going to fail, we want to fail quickly and cheaply. That's true and preferably often. Small. But small, yeah. The problem with Silicon Valley's motto, which no one talks about, is that Silicon Valley, they're fantastic at this sort of fail forward mentality, but they don't learn from their failures. They don't fail mindfully.
失败绝不是我们想要的。如果要失败，我们希望快速且廉价地失败。这是真的，而且最好是经常失败。小规模地。但要小，是的。硅谷座右铭的问题在于，没有人谈论它，那就是硅谷在发挥这种向前失败的心态方面非常棒，但他们并没有从失败中吸取教训。他们没有带着正念去失败。
They fail again and again and again in the same ways. So the rest of the world is like, can look up to them, but they're not doing it in a, in a, in a, in a, in a, in a very mindful way. They don't consistently learn from failures. They don't take the, you know, the deep work and time to get the lessons. You know, you paid for them. You might as well get them. Right. And, and, and, and, but you've got to put that extra in. So I, I, I, I think, yeah, two cavalier resounding yes. And my word for it is it's sloppy, right? It, it, it, it, it applies to some circumstances. but not others. And it's, you know, fail fast, yes, but only, only as fast as possible having done your homework.
他们以同样的方式一次又一次地失败。所以其余的世界就像是，可以仰望他们，但他们并不是以一种非常专注、正念的方式在做这件事。他们没有持续从失败中吸取教训。他们没有花精力和时间去获取教训。你知道的，你为此付出了代价。你不如把它们拿到手。对，而且，但是你得付出额外的努力。所以，我，我认为，是的，太轻率了，响亮的“是”。我给它的词是它很马虎，对吧？它适用于某些情况，但不适用于其他情况。并且，你知道，快速失败，是的，但前提是，只有在做好功课的情况下尽可能快地失败。
You don't just, you know, this isn't a matter of just throwing darts and seeing what sticks. It's, it's a matter of at least having good reason to believe that something might work. Because it's, I am not a fan of wasting resources. I am a fan of learning in smart ways as fast, learn as fast as fast as you can. but no faster because that ends up being waste. Well, this leads me to a question I have to ask, and I didn't necessarily want to call him out. But one of the cool things in the museum is the wall
你不能只是，你知道的，这不仅仅是扔飞镖看哪个能中的问题。这是一个至少有充分理由相信某事可能会成功的问题。因为我是，我不是浪费资源的粉丝。我是以聪明的方式尽可能快地学习的粉丝，尽可能快地学习，但不要比这更快，因为那样最终会造成浪费。好吧，这让我想到了一个我必须问的问题，而且我并不是非要点名。但博物馆里最酷的事情之一就是这面墙，
where people can put up a post-it about whether they think Elon Musk is a failure or a success. Which is it? You're going to have to edit this one out. As a human being, a failure. As a company leader, failure, in many other aspects, but as a visionary willing to take risks, a success in many ways.
人们可以在上面贴便签，表达他们认为埃隆·马斯克是失败者还是成功者。到底是哪个？你得把这段剪掉。作为一个人，是个失败者。作为公司领导者，在很多其他方面也是个失败者，但作为一个愿意冒险的远见卓识者，在许多方面是个成功者。
So I think we, especially these sort of celebrity superstar, mega-rich entrepreneurs, we just see them as one unit. They're not. They can be horrible people, but very good at money. or they can be success, they can be risk takers, and they can be sloppy risk takers that just get lucky. They can, we have to nuance it. So whether Elon Musk is a failure or a success, yeah,
所以我觉得我们，尤其是这些所谓的名人巨星、超级富豪企业家，我们只是把他们看作一个整体。他们不是。他们可能是可怕的人，但很会赚钱，或者他们可能是成功者，他们可以是冒险者，也可以是只是走运的马虎冒险者。他们可以，我们必须具体情况具体分析。所以埃隆·马斯克到底是失败者还是成功者，是的，
I mean, he's a failure in many ways and is failing quite rapidly now with just about everything. But just a few years ago, he was the best success. So these things vary. and we can't just say A or B, you know. You know, that's a really important point. I agree with everything that Sam just said. And I'd add that it's, you know, like it or not, it's true for all of us, right?
我是说，他在很多方面都是个失败者，现在几乎在所有事情上都在相当迅速地失败。但就在几年前，他是最大的成功者。所以这些事情是会变的，我们不能简单地说A或B，你知道的。你知道，这是一个非常重要的观点。我同意萨姆刚刚所说的一切。我想补充的是，不管你喜欢与否，这对我们所有人来说都是真的，对吧？
It's not really the right question to say, is a whole person in their entirety and over time, a success or a failure? We all have failures and successes. And some of that's temporal and some of it's categorical, right? That I can be, as you say, I can be a success in business, but a failure. in my home life or vice versa. So it's really, let's get a lot more precise and nuanced with our application of these words. There's some interesting, there was a historic, there was a book I read on the history of failure. And one of the ideas there was that the concept of a human being being a failure is an
说一个人在整体上和随着时间推移是一个成功者还是失败者，并不是一个真正正确的问题？我们都有失败和成功。其中有些是暂时的，有些是分类的，对吧？正如你所说，我可以在商业上取得成功，但在家庭生活中失败，反之亦然。所以，让我们在这些词的应用上变得更加精确和细致。有一些有趣的书，我读过一本关于失败历史的书。其中的一个观点是，人类是一个失败者的概念是一个，
American invention. So before the industrial, the sort of, in the English language, before capitalistic America and this big industrial sort of boom, only products and
美国的创造。所以在工业革命之前，在英语中，在资本主义美国和这个巨大的工业繁荣之前，只有产品和
constructions, a bridge or a building could be a failure, but in England, the word failure was only used to describe an endeavor or a bridge. Wow. It was a human being couldn't really be a failure, But then in this sort of hyper-capitalistic sort of society that emerged in the United States,
建筑，一座桥梁或一栋建筑可以被视为失败，但在英国，“失败”这个词仅用于描述一项事业或一座桥梁。哇。人类不可能真正成为一个失败者，但在这种在美国出现的超级资本主义社会中，
the concept was if you're not rich enough, you know, with all this opportunity, and you can't avail yourself of everything in this wonderful new world, you must be a failure. So the concept of an individual being a failure is a fairly new concept. But wait, wait. And I'm fascinated with that. Right. But England is notorious for having had those debtors prisons, right, in the 1700s, 1800s. So, I mean, those people were failures as human beings. They weren't called failures,
这个概念是，如果你不够富有，你知道的，拥有所有这些机会，却无法在这个美妙的新世界里利用一切，你一定是个失败者。所以个人是一个失败者的概念是一个相当新的概念。但是等等，等等。我对这一点很着迷。对。但英国以在18世纪、19世纪拥有那些债务人监狱而闻名，对吧？所以，我的意思是，这些人作为人类是失败者。他们当时不被称为失败者，
apparently. We're now adding that lens on later, right? They were debtors. They were, yeah, they had done something they weren't supposed to do. And probably illegal, according to the long of time, yeah. Right. But they weren't fair. But it's in terms of. economic sort of if you're not if you're so smart why aren't you rich or if you're not if you're successful why don't you have money like the the money
显然。我们现在是在事后加上这个视角，对吧？他们是债务人。他们是，是的，他们做了他们不该做的事。而且根据当时的法律，可能也是违法的，对吧。对。但他们并不是失败者。但就经济而言，如果你不是，如果你那么聪明，为什么你不够富有，或者如果你不是，如果你成功了，为什么你没有钱，就像钱这部分
part is the main definition of failure in not just in the United States not but it's been exported to the rest of the world and it's a it's a strange it's a weird phenomenon I think that's really insightful you know I think that
是失败的主要定义，不仅在美国，而且它被出口到世界其他地方，这是一个奇怪的，这是一个奇怪的现象，我认为这真的很有见地，你知道，我认为
it's our our equation of economic success or financial success with success is very deep and oddly, as you say, new. I mean, new in the grand scheme of things, but not new, certainly not new for the last hundred years or more. But if you think about it, it's kind of a weird idea, right? That we've gotten so fixated on one scorecard when there's so many scorecards. And that's the one we now have societally think is preeminent. Not how moral are you, you know, how many people have you helped or, you know, how extraordinary is the literature that you've produced? It's all that single scorecard.
我们把经济成功或财务成功与成功等同起来的做法根深蒂固，而且正如你所说，奇怪的是，它是崭新的。我是说，在大局中是崭新的，但绝不新鲜，在过去的一百年或更长时间里肯定不新鲜。但如果你仔细想想，这真是一个奇怪的想法，对吧？我们变得如此执着于单一的记分牌，而明明有那么多的记分牌。而这正是我们现在在社会上认为最重要的那个记分牌。不是你有多道德，你知道，你帮助了多少人，或者，你知道，你创作的文学作品有多么非凡？全都是那个单一的记分牌。
Yeah, your book is great, but it hasn't sold well. So you're a failure. Right. Right. Even though it's deep, meaningful, thoughtful, what have you. Yeah. So last question I'm going to throw at both of you. what have been some of the failures you've experienced in your career that taught you something important that maybe made you a better scientist, teacher, researcher. Dr. West, throw it at your friend. I can't throw out. I've got a lot of them. My favorite one is kind of trivial, but it has taught me a lesson. When I first got the idea for Museum of Failure, I could just feel like this is a good idea.
是的，你的书很棒，但它卖得不好。所以你是个失败者。对。对。尽管它深刻、有意义、体贴，诸如此类。好的，我要向你们俩提出的最后一个问题。在你们的职业生涯中，有哪些失败经历教给了你们一些重要的东西，也许让你们成为了更好的科学家、老师、研究员。西斯博士，抛给你的朋友吧。我抛不出来。我有很多。我最喜欢的一个有点微不足道，但它确实教了我一课。当我第一次萌生失败博物馆的想法时，我能感觉到这是一个好主意。
So I immediately bought the web domain, museumof failure.com. And this was in 2016. And I thought, wow, I'm so lucky. I'm so smart that this domain is still available. You know, I was just blown away. And then, you know, I celebrated and had a beer. And I thought I was, I'm just such a genius. And then I got the receipt email.
所以我立刻买下了网络域名 museumof failure.com。这是在2016年。我想，哇，我太幸运了。我太聪明了，这个域名居然还在。你知道，我简直惊呆了。然后，你知道，我庆祝了一下，喝了一杯啤酒。我以为我，我真是个天才。然后我收到了收据邮件。
And it said, congratulations, you own Musum of FAA. I must be the only owner of a museum who can't spell the word museum. That's so good. That's so good. That's so good. Attention to be less sloppy. Attention to detail matters. Oh, that's so good.
上面写着，恭喜你，你拥有了 Musum of FAA。我一定是一个连 museum 这个词都不会拼的博物馆馆长。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。注意要少出马虎。对细节的关注很重要。哦，太棒了。
I think mine is less interesting. The ones that come to mind are, well, I'll just say one, a particular paper that was rejected from a journal that I had not even thought was a stretch goal. You know, I thought it was, I thought it was, I should have gotten an R&R. It was, you know, it was, I thought it was good enough. And I was sort of shocked and taken aback again, because it hadn't been a stretch in the first place. And the, what I did next was, I realized there's really two options, you know, well, three, maybe. One is just give up on the paper.
我觉得我的没那么有趣。浮现在脑海中的是，好吧，我只说一个，一篇被某期刊拒绝的特定论文，我甚至没把它当作一个力所能及的目标。你知道，我觉得它是，我觉得它是，我本该得到修改后重新提交的机会。它是，你知道的，我觉得它足够好了。我再次感到震惊和意外，因为它一开始根本不是个力所能及的目标。然后，我接下来做的是，我意识到实际上有两个选择，你知道，好吧，也许有三个。一个是直接放弃这篇论文。
Another is go down market, you know, go to an even, even lower. level journal. And then oddly, there's a third option, which is to go up market. Like, take the feedback seriously, make it better, and then submit it to a different, better journal. And whether cheeky or not, I decided to go that way. And that does, it remains one of my favorite papers. It did get, it did get in, but not, not without some really tough criticism, you know, two or three rounds of review to make it a better paper. And by the end of it, I was really proud of it. And it is absolutely crystal clear that the reviewers and the editor made it better, made it the paper.
另一个是走向低端，你知道，去一个更低水平的期刊。然后奇怪的是，还有第三个选项，那就是走向高端。比如，认真对待反馈，把它改得更好，然后把它投给另一个更好的期刊。不管是不是厚脸皮，我决定走这条路。而且确实，它仍然是我最喜欢的论文之一。它确实被接收了，但并非没有经历一些非常严厉的批评，你知道，经历了二到三轮的评审才使它成为一篇更好的论文。到了最后，我真的为它感到骄傲。而且绝对一清二楚的是，审稿人和编辑让它变得更好，造就了这篇论文。
It became. So I think there was two lessons. One, don't give up. The setbacks are painful, but don't give up. And two, when you go for harder challenges, you actually are setting yourself up to get better feedback. I mean, the quality of the feedback. Not easy, not fun, but being willing to take the sort of the tougher medicine ends up with a product I can feel more proud of. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today. This has been a great conversation. I have really enjoyed talking to both of you.
它最终成为了这样。所以我认为有两个教训。第一，不要放弃。挫折是痛苦的，但不要放弃。第二，当你去挑战更难的挑战时，你实际上是在为自己创造条件以获得更好的反馈。我是说，反馈的质量。不容易，不好玩，但愿意接受这种更严厉的良药，最终会产生一个让我更骄傲的产品。好吧，我要感谢你们俩今天能来。这是一次非常棒的对话。我真的很享受和你们俩交谈。
Thank you very much. Nice meeting you both, especially you, Amy. Big fan of your work. Yeah, likewise. Great big fan. Likewise. This was really fun. So thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills.
非常感谢。很高兴认识你们俩，尤其是你，艾米。我是你作品的超级粉丝。是的，彼此彼此。超级大粉丝。彼此彼此。这真的很有趣。非常谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 www. speakingof psychology.org 或在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》以前的节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。本期节目由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪扬。谢谢收听。美国心理学会。我是金·米尔斯。
I try this hula chair out. And hopefully I don't drop anything. All right. I'm going to Chris while you're on the holsterner's table. Let's try it. I think it's more, uh, all right, let's see. I'm going to press start here. I'm on speed one. All right. This was supposed to be good for you in the office,
我来试试这个呼啦椅。希望我不会掉落什么东西。好的。克里斯，当你在呼啦椅桌上时。我们试试吧。我觉得它更，呃，好吧，让我们看看。我要在这里按开始。我开到一档。好吧。这本该对你在办公室有好处，
because you'd be getting your exercise as you were, I don't know, type in a memo. And it has several speeds. I'm going to speed two. And I don't really know as much, but let's try to take it up to speed six. It's actually pretty good. I don't know. I just dropped the microphone.
因为你在，我不知道，打备忘录的时候可以锻炼身体。它有几个档位。我要调到二档。我其实不太了解，但我们试着把它调到六档。其实还挺好的。我不知道。我刚把麦克风掉了。
I have no idea how high this goes. Let's take it to the max. I think I'm about to be tossed over. Yeah, nine is the max. And yeah, I can probably get work done nine times as fast. All right. enough of this. It's obvious why this one is a failure. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我不知道这玩意儿能升多高。我们把它调到最大。我觉得我快被甩出去了。对，九是最高档。是的，我大概能以九倍的速度完成工作。好了。够了。很显然为什么这个是一个失败之作。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。